[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia tres han sido de los
presidentes de eeuu juzgados
políticamente en el congreso en otras
palabras los que han atravesado un
proceso de impeachment impeachment
significa acusar o presentar cargos
contra un funcionario público desde hace
varios siglos un trámite jurídico inglés
que quedó consagrado en la constitución
de eeuu en 1787 en tiempos en los que
george washington fungía como el primer
presidente de la nación desde entonces
21 jueces legisladores y funcionarios
han sido procesados y entre estos tres
presidentes el primero de ellos fue
andrew johnson en 1868 un demócrata que
contabilizó en su contra 11 artículos de
impeachment johnson fue el
vicepresidente de abraham lincoln
durante la guerra de secesión la única
guerra civil estadounidense de su
historia cuando lincoln fue asesinado en
1865 johnson asumió la presidencia poco
tiempo después en 1868
destacado demócrata anti rebelión del
sur se enfrentó a una mayoría
republicana en el congreso que buscó
destituirlo el punto en cuestión fue el
intento de johnson de reemplazar al
secretario de guerra por uno de su
elección desatando la ira republicana
pero por cuenta de un solo voto en el
senado
johnson fue encontrado no culpable de
sus cargos el impeachment de andrew
johnson sentó un precedente 130 años más
tarde en 1998 bill clinton fue el
segundo presidente de eeuu en ser
procesado por el congreso el caso le dio
la vuelta al mundo comenzó con una
demanda por acoso sexual presentada por
paula jones una funcionaria del estado
de arkansas durante las audiencias los
abogados de jones buscaron construir un
supuesto patrón de relaciones sexuales
entre clinton y funcionarios de la
administración para demostrarlo ante la
corte fueron convocadas varias mujeres
entre las cuales se encontraban monica
lewinsky una becaria de la casa blanca
que se haría famosa durante el juicio se
le preguntó
bill clinton si al día sostenido
relaciones sexuales de cualquier tipo
con mónica lewinsky a lo cual respondió
nunca tuve sexo con esa mujer
el proceso llego a detalles como el de
probar la presencia de semen de clinton
en un vestido azul que le pertenecía a
monica lewinsky de esta manera la cámara
de representantes- inició el proceso de
impeachment contra clinton por los
cargos de mentir bajo juramento y de
obstruir la justicia el escándalo fue
bautizado como mónica gate e impacto a
la opinión pública cuando se reveló que
lewinsky le había practicado sexo oral a
clinton en el despacho de la oficina
oval aunque el impeachment prosperó en
la cámara de representantes- fue
desestimado en el senado al no conseguir
que dos terceras partes lo encontraran
culpable de sus cargos
el 18 de diciembre de 2019 donald trump
se convirtió en el tercer presidente de
los eeuu en ser juzgado políticamente en
el congreso luego de bill clinton en
1998 y de andrew johnson en 1868
a trump se le acusó de abuso de poder y
obstrucción al congreso luego de que
hubiera ejercido presión sobre el
gobierno de ucrania para que llevara a
cabo una investigación en contra de su
eventual contrincante presidencial joe
biden y su hijo hunter dicha
investigación habría ayudado a trump en
su aspiración a la reelección de manera
que los demócratas lo acusaron de
ponerse por encima de la ley y de
ignorar las normas de conducta que debe
tener un presidente y que están
establecidas en la constitución
pero una vez el impeachment alcanzó el
estrado del senado
trump recibió un apoyo incondicional de
su bancada republicana y fue absuelto de
todos los cargos en broadway no tenían
nada y me llevaron a una votación final
de juicio político esa es una palabra
muy fea para mí es una palabra muy
oscura muy fea no tenían nada tenían una
llamada telefónica que era una llamada
totalmente apropiada yo lo llamo una
llamada perfecta porque lo fue y me
llevaron a las etapas finales del juicio
político pero ahora tenemos esa hermosa
palabra suka pensé que una palabra
sonaría también se llama absolución
total
pero tras los eventos de violencia
perpetrados por una turba de sus
partidarios el 6 de enero de 2021
trump se convirtió en el primer
presidente de los eeuu en ser objeto de
un segundo impeachment la cámara de
representantes en cabeza de nancy pelosi
aprobó un segundo proceso de destitución
esta vez por lo que calificó como una
incitación a la insurrección
salto del capitolio ocurrió el mismo día
en que el congreso debía refrendar los
resultados electorales que le dieron la
victoria a joe biden en aquella jornada
trump llamó a sus seguidores a
desconocer los resultados convocó una
manifestación en washington nos llamó a
marchar hacia el congreso y al luchar
como el [__] para impedir la
certificación de la victoria de su rival
para muchos el detonante de los
infortunados y violentos episodios
ocurridos en washington en las cuales
murieron cinco personas cuatro civiles y
un policía por primera vez 10
republicanos apoyaron la moción de
impeachment adelantada por los
demócratas en la cámara este segundo
juicio seguirá su curso incluso con
trump por fuera de la casa blanca y
requerirá de dos terceras partes del
senado para declarar la culpabilidad de
los cargos que se le acusan de ser
encontrado culpable trump puede ser
objeto de una segunda votación esta vez
por mayoría simple para no ocupar cargos
públicos lo cual le impediría
a presentarse como candidato
presidencial en el 2024 como lo ha
sugerido llegamos al final de este
capítulo soy andrés suárez jaramillo
encantado que puedan compartir estas
historias que las encuentran en france
24 punto com
[Música]